last week you were really animated you
were animated you're a little upset you
tell me how ridiculous it was
that i made the statement that lebron
james
now going to the finals
uh with the lakers after being there
with cleveland two different times
yeah and with miami how no one else
could have done that and you were like
well michael could have done it all
here's another reason they couldn't have
done it
one is just a position that he plays
like you you gotta if you have a point
guard a point guard a six one six two
point guard has a lot to make up for
because okay you're dependent on a big
man you're dependent on all these things
that's got to do with my brother jordan
michael well michael jordan because he's
not he was neither 6-2 nor a point guard
so what are you talking about okay
michael jordan well i'll tell you what
michael jordan couldn't have done it i'm
glad you mentioned him first because the
one guy who could have
is probably magic because he's able to
check a lot of boxes just like lebron
i'll tell you why
michael couldn't have done it
part of the reason part of the reason
lebron is able to do it everybody
criticizes him for joining up with other
players right
michael uh lebron is almost like an nba
executive and a player he's like a
player coach executive so he looks at a
situation and he says okay i'd be good
here if i go here i need to bring in
kevin love i need to bring in this
shooter to help me spread the floor all
that stuff
yeah michael jordan we should have known
this
and he's got so many people in the media
kissing his butt that nobody says it but
i will okay i'll stop it but i don't
know i will nobody but i will okay well
watch this watch this lukewarm tape go
ahead what you're about to say a little
bit
no no what you know i'm telling the
truth you watched the last dance just
like i did okay everybody just say hey
michael this michael this uh you know oh
this is great let's just tell them let's
tell the truth about michael jordan even
when he played we should have known it
he was a terrible evaluator when he
played he used to tell jerry krause to
bring in all these north carolina
players that's what he wanted to bring
in and krause was like no so krause was
a better evaluator michael jordan the
player was not a great evaluator and now
we know he's not a great evaluator as an
executive lebron james part of the
reason he's able to get so many teams to
the finals is he's a better evaluator of
talent than michael jordan so that's
what's part of getting him to the finals
so often jordan couldn't have done it
maybe magic could have i can tell you i
know jordan couldn't know because he
didn't evaluate talent like lebron did
bro that was a reach like a bug dog okay
listen
with you first of all
no not even it's it's really really cold
um where do i start god you said a bunch
of bull
um
let's i did last week and i thought
you'd be over it but apparently you've
been sitting with this all weekend all
that my issue was the idea that jordan
magic bird kareem any of the all-time
great players in nba history that you
said they could not have done it when i
think about how hard it is
you realize how difficult this is what i
do
i do i do wait wait wait wait wait i do
and i'm gonna give him props for it but
i just want to kind of like do this one
section at a time because we actually
agree on a lot of things that you said
but specifically as it relates to what
past grades could not have done i just
think it's a move point because they
didn't go that route they didn't but to
say that they could not have
i think is like ridiculous because
that's just saying that lebron is far
and away better at basketball than any
of the aforementioned greats so that's
but if i felt that way but if i felt
that way because they could have changed
franchises the same that he did same way
he did no no no and if i felt that way
if i felt that he was far better than
those guys i would just say he's a
better player than him and i i don't
know if i can say that but the tell me
about you didn't no you didn't but the
talent evaluated apart
he didn't draft carol let's just go
backwards he didn't draft kyrie irving
he didn't trade for kevin love now
certainly he didn't kind of did yeah to
trade for kevin love no he may
it doesn't take a genius to trade for a
dude that was a white muslim alone in
minnesota in terms of statistics
okay so i mean listen how dare you he
of it is said in terms of his statistics
stop it okay
okay go ahead put look at kevin loves
now
they might not have translated into a
lot of wins look at his numbers
minnesota wait a second wait i won't get
on track i wanna try what i'm saying
he is
one of the most brilliant basketball
minds we've ever seen he is a coach on
the floor people thought he was a
difficult person to coach when i beg to
differ i think he made the coach's job
easier we know he makes everybody better
he has a computer for a brain he makes
he makes the right play all the time i'm
with you on his brilliance okay in miami
he had a guy by the name of pat riley
who we'll show love to later pulling the
strings in miami okay so i think pat
riley knows how to construct teams a
little bit better than lebron james does
all right so let's start let's not put
let's let's he's he's the king he's a
king let's not make him the emperor okay
let's let's let's not make him the king
of the world here for a second like he
had help along the way like everybody
else has helped getting there okay
everybody look at the variation
organizational and a supporting staff
standpoint yeah okay look at the array
look at the array of teams that lebron
james has taken to the nba finals though
it's yes he's great he's dead
yes i agree with you
yeah i mean
it's not all the same story each finals
trip is not the same story what is this
final trip number ten now so finals trip
number one we both agree
was one of the worst finals teams i've
ever seen yes
how he how he got that team and i'm
saying it that way intentionally how he
got that team to the nba finals is just
miraculous
i agree
i agree oh okay sure four straight
finals with miami i may have had some
help dwyane wade chris bosh right yeah
pat reilly organization
but then to go back to cleveland
and get that team to the finals again
and get them uh to the finals in
perpetuity pretty much seemed like right
yeah and now to get this lakers team
to the final which by the way
by the way people say oh it's the lakers
you got anthony davis people forget how
bad the lakers were i didn't realize
they they won the fewest games in the
league the five years before we got
there they were in terrible shape before
he got right and there were people
wondering whether he still could do it
and do it in the western conference
and so just because it took him a year
to get him there there in year two it is
an accomplishment in and of itself even
though the lakers have been there 32
times but so i'm with you on on lebron's
greatness so with that in mind let me
ask you this
this is the question i want to get to
you today because
this is the thing i really love that he
said to dave mcmenamin from espn
after the game
asked about that 10th finals appearance
we put up the graphic a couple of times
more than all but three teams
he said right now i don't mean jack
unless i get it done
so
what would a finals loss
we're talking about what a tenth finals
appearance means and how impressive that
is what would a finals loss
if anything mean to lebron's legacy if
he walks away from this three three and
seven i'm not asking who you're picking
i'm not asking you picking but i'm
saying if he works is this serious i got
it
what would it mean would it be a ding on
his legacy he's saying it doesn't mean
anything unless he gets it done i
disagree what do you think
um i disagree with him
because i don't think i don't think it
affects his legacy
uh we we're and you you said this last
week and this is one of the rare things
you said that i actually agree with
um
you said you said last week
that when why are we starting to count
finals appearances
why are we counting this why are we
keeping finals records
uh
we've gone too far with that and i agree
because the guy
who's got his logo right there on the
backboard
jerry west nobody talks about his record
in the finals
now he went to he went to nine finals
do you know what jerry west's uh final
finals record is a player did he win i
think he won one right one in eight was
it yeah he's one and eight he's one and
eight but we don't look at it like hey
jerry west has won it eight in the
finals jerry west was a great player
went to the finals a lot with the lakers
they ran into the celtics a lot and the
celtics got a bunch of victories but
that doesn't diminish jerry west and
what he do what he what he contributed
to basketball and the same thing with
lebron james if if they lose his finals
you can't diminish lebron getting every
time lebron james comes if he comes to
your city
your situation improves if he comes to
your city you've been upgraded
so that's all right
what's that shot right glad we perfect
time i'm glad we brought up that shot
right there that shot of him sit he was
sitting on the court in the with the
confetti falling down just sitting there
deep in thought he was asked after the
game what he was thinking and he said i
started thinking about my journey about
the journey as frank sinatra would say i
did it my way which speaks to what you
talked about earlier his unique path
and that got me to thinking that got me
to thinking
i finally figured out how to look at
this it's taking me a long time it's
taking me 17 years well now he hasn't
always been in the conference the goat
conversation but it's taken me the
better part of a decade since we first
started talking about whether he could
catch jordan or whether he had caught
jordan whether he was better than jordan
it's taking me a long time to actually
see it the right way remember i told you
i had the right answer about the lebron
v jordan conversation i told you a
little bit all right that's here get to
it i'm getting that sure that's it
all right so i told you before that just
to recap my journey
along this conversation i told you
before that i felt like
there was nothing that lebron could ever
do to surpass michael jordan in my mind
i didn't care how many championships he
won i mean mvps there's nothing they
could do that's how i felt for a long
time
what i didn't account for was him
getting better with age
and so i've said recently last couple of
years really i was like man am i going
to have to eat those words or rethink my
stance on that and the answer to that is
no and here's why
lebron has actually succeeded
not in
catching michael jordan not in
surpassing michael jordan
but in separating himself from michael
jordan
i think what's going on
something he's like something that no
other player before him
not the late great kobe bryant
not grant hill not any of the error
parents to his airness
or any of the people who preceded
michael jordan
lebron
has surpassed
and
transcended
trivial comparisons by people like you
to michael jordan
he is his own man he is his own story he
is his own goat
he no no i'm saying all of us like he he
he doesn't he deserves better than to be
reduced to a debate about whether he's
as good or as or better than michael
jordan he is not happy but i haven't
done that he's taken that but i haven't
done that i agree with you but i just
want to point out i'm sorry i don't know
when i say when i say we i mean people
of our ilk i don't mean you individually
michael i mean i mean journalists
talking heads um he has surpassed given
what he's done given the numbers he's
put up giving his accomplishments on and
off the court he has surpassed
being reduced to a debate about whether
he's better than michael jordan there's
only one lebron james and regardless of
whether or not you and i disagree about
whether michael could have done it the
way lebron has done it the fact is that
he didn't do it the way lebron has done
it and here is the analog i know you're
gonna love this
here is the analog that is
that is i think is appropriate this is
the best way i know how to put the
lebron james michael jordan conversation
it is prince versus stevie wonder
it is prince versus michael jackson
it is a matter of preference
it is not a matter of body of work or
ability or brilliance
they did they did it at the highest
level
possible
and completely different
in completely different styles and there
is no wrong answer it's just okay let's
appreciate prince let's appreciate
stevie love people used to like to put
michael jackson and prince against each
other back in the day i prefer prince
for the record but he's still a king of
pop
you know so for michael jordan and
lebron james i think it's something that
is fun to debate but we don't need to
arrive at an answer we certainly don't
need to arrive at a consensus
i think what we can do is step back and
just continue to be witnesses go ahead
let me just ask one one quick question
though
in this prince versus stevie thing
who's lebron and who's jordan i just
want to know
so i know i agree with you i just want
to know who's prince and who's stevie
just so
says i go jordan then lebron for me is
prince then stevie
so stevie is lebron in this in this
analogy for me
princess jordan for me i get the sense
that that might be flipped i think i
think stevie is your guy and then prince
is a close second
right yeah yeah that's right
you